bonjour nouvelle édition du café
politique sur tv fil 78 vue de presse de
l'actualité des quinze derniers jours en
compagnie d'élus de responsables
politiques dans le département et pour
m'accompagner au cours de cette
prochaine demi heure philippe benassaya
bonjour bienvenue ici au bistrot du
théâtre à montigny-le-bretonneux vous
êtes le maire les républicains à de bois
d'arcy
bonjour également à philippe gault mardi
zhu conseiller municipal lutte ouvrière
aubergenville porte-parole yvelines du
mouvement et délégué cgt également chez
renault flins et puis tout à l'heure en
cours d'émission ne nous rejoindra
également nm chili c'est le président
une fds zullino va débuter par de la
politique forcément avec le renoncement
de françois hollande il ne briguera pas
de second mandat manuel valls lui en
revanche se lance dans la bataille de la
primaire à droite hollande n'y va pas il
va vous regarder ça comment peu importe
l'adversaire pour vous non non je
regarde surtout cette fin de quinquennat
qui est une qui est une qui est un
un drame qu à 3-3 premier ministre en
cinq ans un premier ministre en exercice
qui s'en va en plaine en pleine campagne
en pleine bataille j'ai envie de dire là
pour le coup un premier ministre qui va
durer cinq mois qui ne fera absolument
rien
c'est vraiment c'est vraiment une drôle
de période je crois qu'on y retourner un
peu à la ivème république avec ces
changements au gouvernement tous les ans
ou tous les deux ans je veux pas faire
comparaison mais sera que dans le
précédent quinquennat quand même on n'a
eu qu'un premier ministre est là
aujourd'hui c'est quand même une sacrée
pagaille je regrette ça et je vois ça
avec beaucoup de beaucoup de tristesse
parce que c'est c'est quand même notre
pays qui est en jeu et les problèmes ne
sont pas réglés j'ai l'impression que
c'est surtout une guerre d'égos plus
qu'une guerre pour la france
on voudrait c'est la france ça c'est
triste du côté d'une lutte ouvrière 2
questions peut-être déjà votre regard
sur ce gouvernement actuellement et puis
à votre regard aussi sur la question de
la primaire il ya eu la primaire à
droite il va y avoir une primaire à
gauche lutte ouvrière ni participa et se
lance seul dans la bataille
donc tout d'abord sur le sur le
gouvernement sur ce choix de françois
hollande ne pas y aller
un vote sur un circuit
ecopal nous dit au delà on dit
aujourd'hui qui n'ira pas mais les
écoles et d'agrément était déconsidérée
la poterie la mode il est vomie par
population par le travail et concernant
la primaire on a même fait mal de la
primaire contre actrice tout aujourd'hui
risque avec nous c'est un show en fait
c'est pato qui décide c'est vraiment du
patronat des financiers des
licenciements aujourd'hui il ya des
licenciements ils ont donc cessé
d'airbus à l'arrière deux milliards sept
de bénéfices par magelis ans et vous
connaissez pas vous qui les décident ses
côtés les conseils d'administration et
vous
c'est vraiment c'est pas avec ces gens
là quand je pourrai donc beaucoup de mer
de la vie benassaya votre réflexion là
dessus
ce qui est intéressant dans les
primaires de la gauche il faut savoir
aussi respecter les temps démocratique
mais
je rappelle quand même plus patronat le
terme patronne est un terme très très
très ciblée très choisis dans l'ain dans
l'idéologie d'extrême gauche je rappelle
quand même que c'est quand même
l'économie qui fait le social est pas le
social qui fait l'économie
donc il faut qu'on ait une économie très
fort pour pouvoir ensuite après
distribués et ça il faut pas l'oublier
c'est l'objectif quand même de nos pays
de nos démocraties libérales
quand vous parlez du social justement on
peut peut-être parler aussi de ce
rapport qui a été fait par le secours
catholique ces derniers jours concernant
les yvelines sur 14000 personnes ou
familles qui sont suivis dans les
yvelines la proportion de femmes seules
avec enfants rencontrés en point
d'accueil
forte augmentation on est passé à 24 5 %
la part de celles qui sont hébergés à
l'hôtel aussi passe de 8 à 11% 3000
personnes sont actuellement logés dans
des hôtels dans le département dont 50%
d'enfants
c'est beaucoup de chiffres mais derrière
tous ces chiffres il ya des réalités des
difficultés quelles réponses aujourd'hui
philippe baumard on peut faire pour
lutter contre la pauvreté qui s'est
installé comme a du mal à voir à faire
régresser aujourd'hui cette pauvreté la
prostate
aujourd'hui elle vient de quelque part
cette misère qui sert voir ces deux
résultats des politiques qui ont été
menées successivement par la gauche ou
la droite c'est de faciliter les
licenciements
les encours bibi de précarité de travail
sur les points de programme peut-être
parce que là on va rentrer dans le coeur
des propositions il va falloir si
françois fillon qui est votre candidat à
droite l'emporté en 2017 il va falloir
résoudre ce problème de la pauvreté on
est théoriquement encore sous un
gouvernement de gauche et je sais que
françois hollande en 2012 avaient dit
qu'ils avaient ils avaient envie de
réenchanter la france je pense qu'il
nous a désenchanté et c'est vrai que la
misère c'est probablement là je partage
en partie ce que dit mon camarade c'est
c'est que c'est vrai que cette précarité
la s'est accrue alors maintenant il faut
voir toujours ça sur une échelle
historique il faut toujours faut pas
voir simplement sur l'immédiateté
politique est-ce qu'on est plus pauvres
aujourd'hui qu'on ne l'était il ya 50
ans 60 ans parce que notre démocratie
non pas quand même pourvu à notre
bien-être à notre épanouissement depuis
déjà 40 50 ans est-ce que la situation
sociale est meilleur question 1
situation sociale est meilleure
aujourd'hui qu'elle ne l'était dans les
mines il ya 50 60 ans 70 ans dans les
usines renault il ya 40 ans 50 ans pour
voir ça sur une échelle historique
c'est ça qui est important je pense qu
on va accueillir autant de sa table même
chili dont jours vous avez réussi à nous
à nous rejoindre et un petit soucis de
transport ça pourrait être un sujet de
discussion aussi ce matin avec le
président de l'unef à son université de
versailles saint quentin en email
philippe benassaya qui représente les
républicains aujourd'hui c'est le maire
de bois d'arcy et puis là philippe
baumard conseiller municipal lutte
ouvrière aubergenville porte parole du
mouvement dans le département nous
parlons de la pauvreté qui progresse et
de ce rapport du secours catholique
peut-être profiter de votre présence
pour nous faire-part témoigner de la
situation concernant les étudiants est
ce qu'on parle beaucoup de la pauvreté
de ces travailleurs pauvres
les étudiants aussi sont de plus en plus
pauvres une paupérisation des étudiants
qui sont obligés de travailler à côté
quelle est la situation aujourd'hui mais
effectivement c'est elle est assez
claire à cette situation notamment le
voit et un centre d'études qui sont
parus
récemment les shaka universités il reste
toujours aussi élevé on voit qu'il ya
très peu d'étudiants qui arrive à
terminer leur licence en trois ans qui
arrive à valider leur licence en
première année une grande majorité entre
échoue lors de leur première année à
faire leur licence en trois ans pourquoi
parce qu'actuellement on vit dans des
conditions d'études qui sont pas
tenables c'est à la fois à l'aise en
filles qui sont dégradées qui sont
délabrés par une surcharge dans la td et
aussi le fait que oui en tant que jeune
homme actuellement on n'a pas les moyens
de pouvoir vivre au quotidien pour
pouvoir aller en cours de manière
normale c'est un étudiant sur deux qui
travaillant dans ces études et c'est
quelque chose qu'on a pu voir récemment
notamment lors du moment sur leur
travail
quoi qu'on en pense il est quand même un
certain ras-le-bol qui est espagne la
jeunesse fait que en a marre d'être tout
le temps précarisés on en a marre d'être
un peu parce qu'on est jeune forcément
est bizuté à la fois d'une étude est à
la fois sur le marché d'emploi
oui c'est sûr cette paupérisation de
continuer elle ne risque pas de
s'arrêter à la rituelle
ça doit être un point de programmes
importants pour 2017 vous pose la
question à l'un à l'autre la prise en
charge de cette question simple détresse
de la jeunesse aussi des étudiants des
universités avis est ce que j'y suis
tout à l'heure je jeu sans faire trop de
politique sur un sujet sur la jeunesse
mais ce que je disais tout à l'heure
françois hollande avait axé son
programme sur la jeunesse et sur les
enchantements de la france et là je note
que la jeunesse a été totalement oubliés
de ce quinquennat et ça ne veut pas dire
qu'avant c'était encore mieux et que les
autres gouvernements avaient réglé pour
la jeunesse et des étudiants
j'ai été étudiant mot singh
il est arrivé de faire des études j'ai
l'impression de me retrouver il ya
trente ans quarante ans plus tôt trente
ans plus tôt quand j'étais étudiant je
travaillais aussi pendant mes études je
faisais des petits boulots quand j'étais
quand j'étais étudiant mais ça plutôt
pas mal
j'avais des problèmes pour me loger
c'est vrai j'avais deux on était dans
des amphis bondés pas très pas très pas
très propre souvent j'ai l'impression
qu'aujourd'hui ça n'a absolument pas
changé la situation s'est malgré tout
dégradée parce qu'on parle de cette
paupérisation mais aussi d'autres
problèmes nouveaux on va pas entrer dans
tous les détails pour mai mais par
exemple la prostitution des étudiants ça
ça démontre aussi qu'il ya une vraie
difficulté c'est trop petit pour
prostitution par l'ondé des étudiants
pour financer leurs études
effectivement tous universitaires on a
fait des petits boulots mais c'était
souvent des compléments on sait qu'il ya
plus ou moins des galères de trouver un
premier logement
mais là aujourd'hui c'est la réalité
quand même encore pire ans à notre ami
pourra peut-être y répondre parce qu'il
est peut-être plus quelques mois sur sur
sept de mes relances et peut-être aussi
l'émergence actes et les réseaux sociaux
vont fait que peut-être la prostitution
s'est développée en beaucoup plus
facilement dans le milieu étudiant que
qu'avant je ne sais pas si le si je me
souviens plus en tout cas si c'était un
sujet déjà dans il ya trente ans mais
forcément si vous si c'est un phénomène
qui est pérenne la prostitution dans le
milieu étudiant
si c'est par un épiphénomène ou un
phénomène je n'en sais rien mais si
c'est un phénomène c'est que on revient
l'idée que de tout à l'heure sur la
précarité qui touche également cette
jeunesse qui a été totalement totalement
abandonnée j'ai l'impression que rien ne
change en fait dans le milieu dans le
milieu universitaire et
et dans la jeunesse aujourd'hui pour les
ouvrières la prise en compte des
problématiques des étudiants
aussi répondre dans le cadre de la
campagne oui bien sûr toute façon
jean dénonce un peu lassant cette
simulation tu penses et d'exclusion
depuis 2007 avec la réforme des
universités nancière tout fait que
beaucoup de l'université se retrouve en
déficit et qui font des choix
budgétaires par justement j'aime des
difficultés et se concerter qu'il ya
trente mille étudiants dans les
universités
tous les ans les bains assassin il faut
des moyens
aujourd'hui c'est le contraire on sait
moi je donne moins de moyens à
développer en plus c'est pas ce n'est
pas que non seulement aux nouveaux
convertis décor il faut par le problème
de l'éducation nationale
parce que même des la primaire devrait
justement mettre aux moyens aujourd'hui
la prime est mat et moyens pour
l'apprentissage des jeunes de l'école
france mène 6-3 et inégalités c'est
encore le dernier rapport commandé par
et ce problème on peut voir nenê global
mehr largement ont dit les siens ils
sont et des jeunes ont été oubliés
pendant cinq ans en faveur de corée où
je pense qu'il est encore aujourd'hui
quand on voit les débats sur le
présentiel c'est soit le service
militaire obligatoire pour tous soit
section université en saxe et des débats
très sain et qui s'intéresse vraiment
aux pratiques de la jeunesse un peu
caricatural mais vous avez en partie
raison c'est ce qu'on dit est encore
candidat évoque la question de la
jeunesse vous le précisez s'esquisse des
puces que souvent on ne l'évoquent pas
du tout on aurait parlé plutôt de
comment favoriser l'accès à l'autonomie
comment pouvoir que les jeunes puissent
se soigner puisque actuellement moins
jeunes sur trois renonce à se soigner du
fait que cela coûte trop cher toutes ces
pronostics on les voit pas actuellement
sur le devant de la scène et nous ce
qu'on veut mettre en avant c'est le fait
que ben oui actuellement dans les
facultés
la situation n'est pas optimale d'une
crise budgétaire depuis un stand année
il ya plus en plus d'étudiants qui a
accédé en france par quelque chose de
positif saisi n'y a pas plus hésitants
qui est réussie c'est à dire que encore
c'est
c'est un peu parce que on est plus
nombreux mais parce qu'on n'a pas
forcément les mêmes capacités
financières budgétaires culture le
pouvoir réussir c'est toujours une
minorité qui a accès d'un diplôme à la
fin donc c'est face à cela nous pose
réinvestir dans lancement supérieur pour
une clientèle de tous et aussi en tant
que jeune va être obligé de la sb ajouté
tout au long de sa vie avant galéré
effectivement en tant qu'étudiant mais
aujourd'hui une chose nouvelle c'est
qu'on galère aussi quand on accède au
marché de l'emploi on enchaîne les cdd
on enchaîne les stages et c'est un
véritable parcours du combattant pour
finalement arriver à un emploi stable et
face à cela il ya une vraie un vrai
effort qui va nous mener de la part des
politiques ce qui n'est pas du tout
faits puisque dans les discours
complaisant sur le papa de la jeunesse
on en parle d'ailleurs totalement
caricatural
je trouve que vous êtes très peu
mobilisé quand même sur ce calque henin
sur tous ces sujets là par exemple la
masse blanche s'étaient mobilisés dans
le passé parce que manuel valls avance
alors il faudrait dire contrat pour la
loi trail on ajoute moi j'ai pas trouvé
qui avait d'énormes une grande
manifestation de mobilisation mais je
sais pas je me trompe peut-être mais
j'ai pas vu une forte mobilisation des
organisations syndicales jamais été
indulgent avec ce gouvernement
peut-être colisée je sais pas parce que
c'est caricatural de dire que parce que
c'est un gouvernement de gauche l'ont
été on aurait été sympa avec la
politique a été clairement mené ces
politiques aillent en faveur des jeunes
les seules mesures qui ont été mises en
avant l'augmentation des bourses et des
mesures que parce qu'elles ont été
arrachés par les jeunes justement soit
lors des ex champions soit lors le
mobilisation le moment le sur la loi
travail a montré clairement que la
jeunesse et au delà de l'unef quel que
soit l'âge et c'est autre chose
vous voulez faire entendre sa voix avait
conscience que ces conditions de vie et
d'études n'était pas optimal et se
mobiliser du coup en conséquence on
arrache un ensemble de choses les 500
millions d'euros que le gouvernement a à
mis en place à l'issue de ce mouvement
ne sont pas tombés par hasard et surtout
parce que jal est immobilisé nous on a
fait pendant cinq ans fait ce travail
d'interpeller poétique on aura durant
les cinq ans à venir
on l'a fait durant sarkozy on l'a fait
durant landes et donc nous on est là
pour te ment interpeller les politiques
actuellement c'est pas par exemple leur
appareil en rétablissant le blues à
l'école ou une histoire du roman
national qu'on arrivera à répondre aux
politiques de jeunesse c'est un peu au
delà et c'est là dessus que mettre
l'accent au delà des questions
d'éducation maintenant on va parler de
ce monde du travail aussi et la
situation au sein du groupe renault va
profiter de votre présence renault qui a
annoncé que les salaires devraient
augmenter au cours des trois prochaines
années
refermant la page de modération
salariale sur la période 2014 2016
est-ce que vous
vous voyez laissé pour l'instant il ya
des discussions en cours
pour l'instant rien de concret n'a été
annoncé sur les augmentations de salaire
générales pour les salariés que le monde
du travail aujourd'hui
il parle vaguement d'augmentations
individuelles mais on n'en sait pas plus
si c'est dans le même
c'est ce qu'ils annoncent va dans le
même sens dans le sillage ce qui a été
fait auparavant
il faut pas espérer beaucoup des
salaires il on commente pas depuis le
depuis de nombreuses années et nous en
tant que délégué cgt
les camarades de travail on pense que on
il faut pas en attendre grand chose de
ces discussions
ce qui peut changer les choses si les
salaires ils pourront augmenter que si
vraiment les salariés bien ils montrent
leur colère pour de véritables
augmentation de salaire qui est des
mobilisations des luttes sociales qui
fera que les salaires augmenteront
aujourd'hui des discussions en cours ben
voilà inaboutie sur pas grand chose et
au delà des discussions sur le salaire
on a surtout entendu parler aujourd'hui
dans cette pré campagne électorale de le
temps de travail est-ce qu'il faut
augmenter le temps de travail par
exemple
c'est le temps de travail s'est passé
l'autre boutre l'autre boudent des
discussions ou les patrons que ça soit
chez renault ou ailleurs ils veulent
augmenter le temps de travail pour
augmenter la surexploitation
c'est à dire que nous faire travailler
plus pour gagner autant s'y voir sinon
moi c'est en fait le but c'est de faire
grossir des profits
voilà essayer de les actionnaires mais
sans mettre un peu plus dans les poches
mais voilà le seul le seul véritable
sens de cette discussion sur le temps de
travail c'est vraiment vraiment
augmenter la surexploitation des
salariés me philippe benassaya votre
candidat républicain françois fillon qui
porte cette déréglementation du temps de
travail vous la soutenez c'est une bonne
position
alors d'abord il se passera rien pour
répondre un peu assure sur les salaires
il se passera rien pendant cinq mois
donc il faut rien attendre un sas et on
est dans une
on est dans le money time comme on dit
dans le dans le sport il faudra attendre
les élections présidentielles pour pour
le prochain gouvernement et prochain
président puisque je pense que ces voix
là et au rapprochement presque
répression politique
on le sait depuis quelques jours
maintenant donc voilà il faudra attendre
faudra attendre le prochain le prochain
le prochain gouvernement non on est le
seul pays au monde à avoir fait les 35
heures donc soit on est extrêmement
intelligent extrêmement lucide et soit
on est complètement à côté de la plaque
je pense qu'on est complètement à côté
de la plaque parce que si les 35 heures
avaient marché ça se verrait aujourd'hui
je crois que le chômage augmentait
depuis 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans donc
j'ai l'impression que les 35 heures
n'ont rien réglé
si on repassait aux 32 heures autant
mettre la clé sous la porte ou dessous
je pense qu'on passe à quoi car
aujourd'hui tous
je pense que l'erreur de la droite oui
c'est très lucide je suis pas je suis
pas un militant
mais l'erreur de la race est pas avoir
supprimé les 35 heures je pense qu'il va
falloir revenir à temps de travail un
petit peu plus important ou alors
laisser le choix par par branche ou
entreprise de revenir ou pas sur les
temps ça je crois qu'il faut un peu de
liberté dans ce pays
le problème le problème si je suis un
peu politique a pour le coup c'est que
le problème de la gauche et que son
souci d'égalitarisme freiner bloc un
petit peu les libertés individuelles et
je crois qu'aujourd'hui il faut que ce
pays retrouve un peu de liberté
notamment sur plan du travail sur plan
de l'emploi les sont les entreprises qui
créent la richesse c'est pas l'état qui
travers richesse c'est l'entreprise qui
crée la richesse
laissons les entreprises à régler ce
problème là par branche et puis après
voilà mais surtout si c'est possible ou
si françois fillon l'écouté mais ça
m'étonnerait surtout supprimer les 35
heures en tout cas supprimer ce carcan
voilà c'est de cette valeur absolue que
sont les 35 heures mais travailler plus
pour gagner plus d 39 heures payées 39
ou des 39 mais ce que je veux dire c'est
à dire et laisser laisser les
entreprises travailler comme elle le
souhaite voir éventuellement travailler
plus pourquoi pas pour gagner plus
est ce qu'on a décidé sans sortir ou pas
voilà donc si la réponse est les 35
heures a priori non puisque ça n'a pas
marché jusqu'à maintenant
donc laissons un petit peu les
entreprises régler ses problèmes par
manche vous qui êtes étudiante au mans
vous serez sur le monde du travail
marché du travail travailler plus
travailler moins regarde un peu mon
regard sur ce débat c'est un peu celui
aussi j'ai sur la jeunesse sait on a les
mêmes propositions un peu caricatural
cdr année quand on regarde le débat est
la première à droite est passé on a eu
le temps de voir chaque candidat de
droite c'est l'esprit sont là dessus si
on est un peu dans le même schéma de ces
dernières années on parle encore et qu'
il faut régler ton travail ce tarif
terrain mais à aucun moment et c'est
pareil quand on garde du production à
gauche d'ailleurs c'est on imagine le
monde qui vient c'est à dire par son
l'action la transition écologique on
parle pas de la transition numérique on
prend pas en compte finalement toutes
les formes de travail qui sont en train
d'émerger
l'ubs et risation extérieur on prend pas
en compte aussi comment le monde du
travail va évoluer dans les prochaines
années ça c'est inquiétant puisque on
raisonne avec les mêmes pensées les
mêmes schémas un peu caricaturaux sans
essayer d'imaginer mais les idées pour
ben voilà comment on va permettre à tous
de travailler demain comment à permettre
à tous de travailler dignement si un peu
le regard que je parle là dessus c'est
un débat souvent avec les mêmes
personnes et souvent avec les mêmes
idées pas forcément intéressant du coup
je pense pas forcément mais le débat est
là dessus c'est notamment la jeunesse de
faire émerger de nouvelles promotions je
pense urbain comment on réinvente la
lutte entre deux projections de demain
comment et abbott
comment graver votre pardon des formes
de production plus équitable plus
responsable pour permettre à tous de
vivre dignement et aussi de prendre en
compte toutes les les nouveaux défis de
demain
la chronologie de trop sur le numérique
ça pendant longtemps pas trop évoquer
nos débats donc 32 35 39 heures ça se
perd ma position
ce que je dis c'est que là il faut pas
seulement raisonner en termes de durée
de temps de travail c'est aussi au delà
sur les formes de travail qu'il faut
actionner ce que je dis en tout cas
c'est que la presse montrait
actuellement aux salariés en tout cas je
vais pas parler à leur place ce salarié
dire ce qu'il pense en tout cas
récemment au père noël
le regard que j'ai sur ses basques il
est assez assez caricature avec les
mêmes dogmes d'un côté l'autre on veut
abattre les 35 heures on sait que c'est
ce que pense la droite je pense pas que
c'est forcément les meilleures solutions
pour l'avenir
ils vont termine comme à chaque fois ce
café politique avec un dernier tour de
table ce que vous retenez chacun de
l'actualité des
quinze derniers jours qu'est ce qui vous
a marqué dans l'actualité aulas
plusieurs choses
plusieurs choses sportivement je suis un
peu déçu par ce qui s'est passé mardi
soir au parc des princes mais ça c'est
une réalité parlons sérieux non moi ce
qui m'a plu c'est quand même malgré mes
réserves
la bonne tenue de la primaire de la
droite il faut être honnête c'était pas
notre c'était pas notre exercice le plus
le plus simple est a priori ça c'est
quand même plutôt bien passé quatre
millions d'électeurs voilà il n'y a pas
eu
il ya eu de vrais débats avec 2,2 des
rassemblements des incohérences des
cohérences dé cohésion mais ça c'est
plutôt quand même assez je souhaite que
la première gauche je passe très très
bien le défi doit être relevée quand
même parce que quatre millions
d'électeurs c'est beaucoup je souhaite
que les gauches parce que là pour le
coup ya plusieurs gauches qui vont
s'affronter dans cette primaire fassent
une bonne primaire et et que le débat
démocratique que se déroule bien
ensuite il ya plein d'autres choses la
situation internationale me préoccupe
énormément ce qui se passe en syrie sur
tout ça c'est la lfc à alep
je suis très inquiet aussi sur les
minorités en orient aussi qui me qui
m'interpelle depuis déjà des mois mais
surtout depuis depuis quelques semaines
et puis voilà quoi y'a pleins pleins
d'autres choses mais ce sera peut-être
le l'objet d'une autre émission tout à
fait on aura le temps de revenir sur
tous ces sujets c'est sûr dans les
prochaines semaines prochains mois ce
que vous retenez dans l'actualité en
chine a très brièvement ce je retiens
c'est que alors qu'il ya six mois d'une
jeunesse et qui se mobilisent
massivement soit dans ce mobile ont
directement soit les enquêtes d'opinion
montrant un peu son ras-le-bol et sont
sentis dit la situation actuelle
aujourd'hui la thématique de la jeunesse
les pâtres extrêmement présente dans les
débats publics soit élections la
présidentielle ou même convoi
déclarations de françois hollande alors
qu'il annonce qu'il se représentera pas
ils sautent officie de son bilan sur des
questions pourraient avoir bien peu plus
critique
donc ça ce que je retiens des débats un
peu hors sol qui ne veut pas forcément
les vrais sujets qui est qu'il est qu
elle les évoque lui n'évoque pas
forcément la bonne manière je lisais
quand on parle du temps de travail qu'on
a vu qu'on n'évoque pas les changements
de modes de production c'est un peu
compliqué je trouve qu'on évoque la
jeunesse seulement sous le prisme de il
faut l'éduquer via un service militaire
obligatoire ils font ça que cette bonne
solution
donc c'est ce que nous on fera cette
jeunesse et
fiancé interpellé faire entendre nos
voix et montrer qu'il ya d'autres
solutions qui existent que les jeunes
les jeunes demande autre chose qu'un
seul vic obligatoire ou je ne sais quoi
d'autre et c'est un peu tout ce qu'on va
faire durant les prochains mois et
prochaines semaines
très bien et pour vous pour conclure
pour conclure
voilà on l'a bien vu dans les débats
que ce soit à droite à gauche ou moins
voire l'extrême droite qu'ils aspirent
tous à gérer cette société à la gérer
mais pour les intérêts des plus riches
on le voit il même le front national qui
se dit hors système il aspire aussi à
gérer ces sociétés là ils en profitent
même il est englué dans des histoires
des soupçons sur le feu sur leur
financement de leur parti sur les
régionales et législatives où le voit
ces gens là eh ben ils aspirent tous à
gérer cette société en fonction des
intérêts des plus riches des
capitalistes moi ce que je peux dire
c'est que l approche des élections le
seul vote qui sera vraiment utile ça
sera de voter le camp le camp des
travailleurs le vote nathalie arthaud
pour justement retrouver la dignité des
travailleurs qu'ils affirment un peu
leurs idées en votant
lutte ouvrière dont pour le camp des
travailleurs la campagne est lancée
chacun soutient son candidat c'est parti
pour cette campagne 2010 est merci à
tous les trois en tout cas d'être venu
pour ce café politique prochain numéro
ce sera le 21 décembre
[Musique]